[Música]
o meu pai ele sempre teve o hábito de me
cumprimentar com uma pergunta
olhava diretamente nos meus olhos e me
perguntava filho
a luta continua
por muito tempo eu não consegui entender
o que significava lutar e mais do que
isso eu não sabia
pelo que eu estava lembro que esse
questionamento começou a ficar muito
forte durante o ensino médio onde
precisamos tomar algumas decisões sobre
carreira sobre qual o futuro a gente vai
correr atrás
na época eu fazia ensino médio junto com
um técnico em mecatrônica no quadro da
unicamp
meu pai é engenheiro elétrico meu tio
engenheiro mecânico então estava com o
caminho delineado
eu seguirei aqui aquela mesma trajetória
só que ao mesmo tempo eu senti um
chamado crescente para estudar
comunicação arte e publicidade
eu tinha um terceiro sonho que era
montar um carrinho de caldo de cana
eu sempre fui muito viciado em caldo de
cana e eu percebi que na minha cidade
ninguém investia para tentar fazer um
negócio em cima disso ela sempre só o
carrinho
esses questionamentos eles mexeram até
com a minha irmã que ela vai começar
comigo um dia na época era cinco anos
mais nova
ela continua cinco anos mais nova e ela
e ela falou da av
se você realmente foi seguir seu sonho e
montar um carrinho de caldo de cana e
vou com você ou vender pipoca porque eu
gosto muito e pipoca
eu lamento decepcionar esse não é um
tédio sobre como dois irmãos criar um
negócio de caldo de cana que toca mas a
história tão boa quanto quando eu
comecei a pensar sobre jornada sobre o
percurso o que o qual seguiria
eu fui falar com o meu grande mentor
falar com meu pai eu falei 'pai eu sei
que estou estudando nem quattrone catão
seguindo ou esse caminho para engenharia
só que a cada dia que passa eu sinto um
chamado para a comunicação pra artes
eu queria saber que você acha que a
expressão facial era total preocupação
enquanto ele falava assim pesquisa olha
às vezes vale a pena eu comecei a
investigar o porquê ele estava com
aquela ansiedade porque ele ficou
preocupado e eu percebi que o maior
motivo era uma preocupação um pouco
financeira que acreditava que se eu
seguisse o caminho da engenharia caminho
já estava delineado já tinha um sucesso
garantido então propôs um desafio eu
tinha 16 e 17 anos
eu falei pai se no próximo mês eu
consegui levantar cinco mil reais só
usando comunicação e arte
acho que seria uma prova para que
realmente mostrar que esse caminho é
bacana e dou risada inflam tudo bem
filho pode discar durante o próximo mês
eu desenvolvi um projeto de uma blusa
para o meu colégio e colocar o logo da
unicamp gigante nas costas porque eu
sabia que meu pessoal é muito novo tinha
15 até 18 anos
ele tinha muito orgulho de fazer parte
da unicamp tão cedo
a gente vem muito rápido vendeu mais de
100 unidades e passou em muito o valor
que foi pré estipulado
aquilo foi bacana porque não não apenas
mostrar o meu pai que era um caminho
legal mas também foi a partir daquele
momento que eu me disse que eu decidi me
tornar um design muito prazer meu nome é
davi rodrigues
hoje já se passaram mais de dez anos que
eu trabalho com um design comunicação e
que hoje aqui eu vim compartilhar um
pouquinho dessa paixão que eu tenho com
um design com vocês
o primeiro ponto é a gente tentar
entender o que é o design como ele
funciona
se a gente olha isso um dicionário a
gente percebe que o des
aine ele pode ser o conceito de qualquer
produto ou serviço baseado na forma como
ele funciona como ele se parece ponto de
vista estético
só que esse conceito é abstrato é
difícil a gente colocar ele no cotidiano
de um dia a dia
quando a gente olha para as pessoas que
trabalham com o design fica muito mais
fácil
então a gente tem por exemplo um
designer gráfico que ajuda você a criar
o seu logo sua identidade visual
a gente tem também designer de interface
que pensa nos detalhes o aplicativo que
você utiliza no dia a dia aqui para se
comunicar para se relacionar
a gente tem um design de interiores que
consegue projetar esse espaço imaginar
onde que tem que ficar uma porta onde
também fica o palco qualquer entrada
ideal para colocar uma escada
só que não pára por aí a gente tem
designer de processo design de produto
design de jóias até design de
sobrancelha e o que conecta essas
pessoas peres tem essa paixão pelo
design
então eu gosto de olhar pra grandes
titãs do design e pensar como eles
pensam é tipo tentar entrar na mente
deles
um deles foi steve jobs que ele define
que o design é apenas como aquilo parece
como você sente como o cheiro toque ele
também é muito como aquilo funciona a
gente tem também o jardins públicos -
designer de experiência e define que
qualquer pessoa que influencia no
processo do que o design se torna
automaticamente a pessoa já é um
designer e por último eu trago tim tim
brown
ele define que o design está em todo
lugar
dessa forma qualquer pessoa é um
designer
eu demorei um pouco pra assimilar esses
conceitos esse título design porque eu
pensava nossa mas só isso que faz um
tempo 15 67 anos faculdade graduação
curso técnico e qualquer pessoa pode ser
um design
o designer qual que essa idéia que eles
queriam passar e não à toa que estou
chamando lhes gigante tanto design
se a gente puxa um pouco na mitologia a
gente tem prometeu prometeu foi um titã
que ele foi até o olimpo roubou o fogo
dos deuses e trouxe até os seres humanos
de tal forma que as pessoas passaram a
sentar em volta de uma fogueira
conseguiram cozinhar seu próprio
alimento facilitou a caça do que esse
mito traz pra gente é que foi uma pessoa
no caso um titã que ele pegou um
conceito complexo pegou um problema e
ele conseguiu desmistificar isso de tal
forma que ele trouxe uma solução que
ficou acessível para qualquer pessoa e
comecei a pensar e se fosse possível
assim como esses grandes titãs conseguem
pegar se essa problemática ação e
torná-la mais acessível gente consegue
pegar essa energia do design e colocada
dentro de uma caixinha como fez com o
fogo a gente pegou essa energia do fogo
e colocou numa caixinha hoje um momento
você pode tirar um fóssil e acender pra
contar uma história pode ascender pra
acender uma fogueira e essa idéia de
usar essa energia trazê la para o mundo
do design onde você tivesse uma caixinha
que você tirasse ela do bolso e você
conseguisse risca e utilizar e utilizar
essa energia para realizar projetos
realizações a mesma coisa que eu
descobri aqui fazer isso sozinho é
impossível então chamei um grande amigo
que é o felipe las assim como eu tenho
essa paixão porque aviso que a visual
porque é palpável
o felipe tem uma paixão pelas palavras
por tornar conceitos complexos em frases
cada vez mais simples e juntos a gente
passou a pesquisar tentar criar uma
metodologia que através do design
facilitar o desenvolvimento de projetos
o que a gente percebeu é que a
metodologia não faltou a gente tem
metodologia é excelente pra desenvolver
modelos de negócios e tecnologias
incríveis para você pensar no design do
seu produto qual seria o valor ideal pra
você entregar os seus clientes para ter
mais performance na execução do trabalho
para pensar de forma diferente para
conseguir fazer a gestão de tarefas
gestão de equipe para fazer protótipo
o que a gente pensou é pegar essa
energia dessas metodologias que já
existem e colocava toda dentro de uma
única caixinha
então a gente cria nossas duas caixinhas
de fósforos
a primeira foi o essencial
focado no desenvolvimento de projetos
muito tempo parte de modelo modelagem do
negócio e o segundo e chamou de insights
que a partir do momento que você já
desenhou seu modelo de negócio
você começa a pensar em como protótipo a
ele como fazer a gestão da sua equipe às
quartas elas foram divididas em diversas
categorias onde em cada uma das cartas
no verso você tinha o nome daquela
categoria para que ela servia ea
quantidade de cartas para que você
pudesse ter mais facilidade de montar e
escolher ali não é desenvolver seu
projeto como aquelas cartas funciona no
verso da carta
além da categoria a gente colocou o qr
code que caso a pessoa tivesse
dificuldade naquele conceito
basta pegar o celular ligado aquele
símbolo e era direcionada para um site
onde explicavam não apenas a carta mas
também a categoria como um todo
lembro até hoje a primeira vez que eu
testei o protótipo
eu ficava o que lhe vai no bolso
procurando momento para testar alguém
que não fosse o mesmo e eu estava num
churrasco de família e meu primo veio
conversar comigo e falou da vinheta
pensando em montar uma modelo de de
negócio focado em doce junto com a minha
namorada de ficar perfeito sempre comigo
eu sentei puxa baralho e achou muito
estranho
peguei nove cartas para modelagem de
negócios e fui fazer algumas perguntas
pra ele
então perguntei a primeira oferta de
valor proposta de valor porque o seu
negócio é diferente dos outros porque é
especial
ele pensou um pouco e respondeu ah eu
quero que o sabor seja incrível e ao
mesmo tempo eu quero que seja saudável e
foi ok ela 32 pontos
o segmento de cliente que vai comprar
esse doce pra quem você vai vender
ele pensou novamente respondeu ao
pessoal da minha faculdade e faculdades
da minha namorada e pessoal na academia
eu falei aqui a nota os dois pontos
pessoal que treina os universitários
a gente ficou mais uma hora e meia
conversando tanto foi desenhado por
exemplo relacionamento
como é que você vai se comunicar com as
pessoas vai ser facebook whatsapp mandar
um e mail pra eles canal como é que você
vai entregar esse doce você vai entregar
pessoalmente vai deixar a academia vai
deixar a universidade
depois de uma hora e meia ele olhando
esse processo e já tinha desenhado quase
que modelo de negócio inteiro do projeto
ele olhou pra mim falou o nosso davi é
tão simples assim criar modelos de
negócio
foi aí essa parte é fácil agora a parte
difícil é você colocar isso na prática e
testar validar sua ideia correr atrás
ver o que funciona o que vai ter que
melhorar e mostrar e algumas outras
cartas
então por exemplo ele falava para mim
que vai ser super saboroso e
supersaudável pega por exemplo postos de
valor como aquele prova isso como é que
prova se realmente gostoso e leva no
grupo para testar como é que ele testa é
nutritivo ele faz uma parceria com o
laboratório é protecionista e posso
crescimento está riscando que os
universitários vão comprar aquele doce
será que eles vão comprar testando
também junto com as pessoas da academia
é um doce será que o pessoal vai olhar
pra que ele vai realmente acreditar que
é saudável
então são pontos que precisam ser
testados e depois desse primeiro teste
desse primeiro vai a verificação eu
conferi que a gente levou o bar em
diversos lugares
a gente já testou o shopping com
pequenos grupos já levamos para dentro
de grandes corporações para testar 10
com um estagiário para criar um novo
produto até com grandes executivos para
validar processos ver se tinha alguma
falha durante a construção daquilo tudo
a gente também levou no google campos
para não apenas mostrar a metodologia
mas mostrar como através de
financiamento coletivo a gente arrecadar
o dinheiro para tornar aquela idéia em
realidade e quando este terminou esse
projeto ele imprimiu só algumas unidades
e para verificar se realmente funcionava
a gente começou a se questionar se é que
essa mesma metodologia poderia ser
aplicado em uma área completamente
diferente e conversando com o felipe e
ele decidiu trabalhar com a construção
de histórias
quem é apaixonado por narrativa por
stone storytelling
e aqui em que o barco foi a saga do
escritor
assim como ele pegou essas metodologias
para desenvolvimento de projetos
a gente criou então uma metodologia para
desenvolvimento de narrativas onde a
gente selecionou ferramentas como
construção de cenário o roteiro
personagem
a gente transforma em cartas bem
próximas do que a gente tinha feito com
um startup
a principal diferença foi que a gente
conseguiu uma parceria com o selo da
tailândia que ele gostou tanto do
projeto que ele consegue fazer uma
liberar algumas artes para tornar o
processo da construção da história ainda
mais lúdica ainda mais divertida
isso aqui é uma parede que o felipe
começou a montar onde estava dizendo uma
história na parte superior
ele tem 12 cartas onde tem a jornada do
herói que você consegue mapear todos os
passos que seu prato para o seu
protagonista ele vai percorrer é a
metodologia utilizada no cinema em
grandes histórias com um hattrick senhor
dos anéis e harry potter na parte
lateral a gente colocou cartas de enredo
que ao mesmo tempo que você planeja a
saga do herói
você já vai mapeando os pontos de enredo
que são necessários você colocar pra
construir essa narrativa em cartas pra
construção de personagens através de
éticos facilidades para a construção e
para você imaginar o cenário ele também
pensou nas partes de planejamento onde
você pensa onde você vai escrever por
quanto tempo quantas palavras por dia
porque não basta só parte da
criatividade
a gente tem também a parte da ação de
colocar tudo aquilo na prática quando as
pessoas me perguntam por que correr
tanto atrás disso tem tratamento hoje é
precisa facilitar ainda mais com que o
que te motiva
eu lembro muito do nosso primeiro
workshop feminino kevin kevin spacey
novo na época tinha 17 anos e estava na
programação este é um grande sonho de
conseguir criar um aplicativo que ajuda
os cuidadores de cães
neste momento no shopping ele já tinha
terminado todo o desenho do modelo de
negócio e estava numa segunda fase
pensando em perfil de cliente e mapa de
valor e sorriso é muito forte para mim
porque nesse momento o cab estava se
tornando designer da sua própria
experiência sem saber os conceitos de
design
ele estava colocando em prática
conceitos complexos que às vezes demoram
anos aí pra você pegar de uma forma
super simples
estou muito realizado
eu conversei com ele é um pouco tempo
perguntei a ele se tocou o projeto fez
acontecer o aplicativo ele colocar
aquele projeto não só que depois que
você passou aquela ferramentas já que o
aplicativo para ajudar pessoas estão
treinando com o aplicativo parte fitness
e está trabalhando agora no outro
aplicativo para ajudar dentistas
eu achei incrível e ele falou que os
conceitos que aprender utilizando
startup até hoje fazem sentido para ele
e essa foto também ela ajuda a responder
a questionamento que meu pai sempre fez
eu aprendi que essa pergunta
ela tem duas grandes premissas para você
conseguir responder você luta você tem
que primeiro saber o que te move qual é
o grande propósito qualquer sua luta ea
segunda grande premissa é que você quer
acreditar tanto nisso que você nunca
para derrotar o terceiro ponto aqui é
que hoje eu não tenho mais o meu pai
para responder isso olhando nos olhos
dele assim como ele perguntava pra mim
só que eu consigo responder essa
pergunta através do legado dele que
permanece em mim então eu respondo sim
pai eu continuo lutando para empoderar
as pessoas através do design é seu
conhecimento
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]